hey hey hey what's going on guys there
you go I made it a little bit easier for
those of you who think you're funny and
you post a little comments below saying
oh my gosh pause at zero : 0 3 his face
is so funny just remember you can't
pause real life but yes I know I need to
shave I know I need to get a haircut but
it's definitely not as bad as that one
time that I let it go all the way down
to my shoulders alright you for a sec
I'm Rob from YouTube I can make you some
origami out of that paper nice that's
really me here's a dollar
thank you so much alright so I think
it's time to get rid of this stuff
much better better as far as folding
paper for money in all seriousness I
would definitely do it for a good cause
and right now a great cause is the
Japanese relief effort as you all know
Japan was recently affected by an
earthquake and tsunami and my thoughts
go out to all of the families and
everyone who was involved or affected by
this tragic natural disaster there's an
ancient Japanese legend that says if you
fold a thousand paper cranes you'll be
granted a wish paper cranes also
symbolize hope strength and healing and
I've been getting many comments recently
on my paper crane tutorial saying that
people are using these cranes to show
support to Japan they're trying to raise
money to give to various foundations
people who are trying to make a thousand
cranes even those who say their school
has used my video to teach how to make
them this is an awesome way to show
support and an easy way to raise money
to help Japan rebuild I know you guys
are saying what can I do to help and
there's a whole bunch of foundations and
also groups out there dedicated
specifically for this cause one viewer
let me know about a Facebook group at
facebook.com slash paper cranes for
Japan the group now has over 9,000
members and people have been posting
pictures of the paper cranes they folded
for the cause the group has teamed up
with a foundation and for every crane
sent in to the address they will donate
$2 to the Japan River
ever the Red Cross is also accepting
donations and I'm going to post a link
for that in the video description down
below so be sure to check that out
because I really like what this Facebook
group is doing I'm going to hold a
contest whoever makes the most paper
cranes to send in to this address here
for the Facebook group is going to win
the rules are pretty simple you need to
make as many of these as you can and
post a video response to this video
saying hey Rob
my name is into you name here and these
are the paper cranes that I made for
Japan you don't have to say your real
name you don't have to show your face
but you do have to have that somewhere
in your video once you've made all the
cranes you need to arrange them in
groups of five and then count them on
the video so I'm going to do a quick
example of what I'm looking for hey Rob
my name's origami master zero six to
nine and these are the paper cranes that
I made for Japan so as you could see I
put them into groups of five like you
asked and I had two rows total so if we
count them I have five ten cranes in all
now sure you're going to make more than
ten cranes but I think you get the idea
put them into groups of five show me how
many cranes you did on video and then
count them all by five as far as putting
the cranes into groups because you might
not be able to line them up all nice and
neat like I did and put them all over
your entire place you can also put them
into groups of five by flattening them
out putting a rubber band around them
just like this and as you count them you
could just put them into one big pile
and when you're done you could be like
there's my 150 cranes I am awesome I
think it would just make things a little
bit easier and I know I don't have to
say this but just be sure to have
exactly five cranes in each group you
can find all the official rules in the
video description down below so be sure
to read that also feel free to help me
judge on this all of the video responses
need to be in by Friday April 8th at 7
o'clock p.m. Eastern Standard Time at
which point I'm going to shut off the
video responses I'm going to start going
through all of them I'm going to comment
I'm going to like them but you want to
know what is the winner get well whoever
has the most cranes in their video is
going to be featured on my channel until
that video has over a thousand views not
only that but I'll put a clip of your
video in one of my future videos if you
want give you a shout out and link to
your channel and a huge
hi-five some of you might be saying well
I don't have a video camera right now or
I don't want to be on video or I don't
have paper yeah sure whatever the reason
is if you post paper cranes for Japan in
the comments section below I'm going to
choose five random people who are going
to be featured in my next video also so
that's how the contest is going to work
and the cool thing about it is that
although it might be difficult for us to
fold thousands of cranes on our own if
we all team up together then it should
be really easy especially because I know
that most of you guys are already paper
crane making pros so not only can we
raise money but maybe we can also get
some wishes out of this and if we can I
would definitely wish that Japan had a
fast recovery and that everyone had the
strength to rebuild now I hope that
doesn't spoil the wish but maybe you
guys can wish for something similar
also please know I will be sending in
the cranes that I made to the Facebook
group and making a donation to the Red
Cross even if you guys don't win the
contest it would still be really cool if
you sent in your cranes and took part in
a cause because I haven't put out a
video in a while I wanted to update you
guys on what's going on with me I am
back in school and it's just really hard
right now to find the time to kind of
balance school my own life and YouTube
YouTube kind of has a life of its own I
mean I put out a video and all of a
sudden you know within a year it has
like a million views and I have over
60,000 subscribers and I really just
wanted to thank you guys so much for
well I really wanted to thank you guys
for the support it's really great you
know I hope that you're gaining
something from this because I'm really
gaining some I'm really gaining a lot of
see this is what happens this is why it
takes me so long to make videos because
I always mess things up and have to cut
it and stuff but uh yeah thank you guys
so much I really appreciate it and I'm
glad that you guys would enjoy watching
my videos and I really enjoy getting
feedback from you so thank you all so
much for your support I did have a
vacation earlier this month for spring
break mean a bunch of friends went on a
road trip to Myrtle Beach in South
Carolina and we stopped it south of the
border and I got attacked by a
hippopotamus hmm it was really nice to
have a break from school and I had a
really great time I saw some nice
scenery and I got to see my first
sunrise on the beach oh well hello there
good morning also not sure if you guys
got to see the super moon but I got a
really close
with my brother's telescope
you can check out his channel by
clicking on this little link up here one
last thing I'd like to say was that you
can now get to my channel by going to
youtube.com slash Robb TV and I'd like
to thank YouTube a lot for setting that
up for me
my name is Robb age 0 6 to 9 and it's a
little hard to remember but now you can
get to it by going to youtube.com slash
Robb TV thank you guys so much for
watching I'm really looking forward to
seeing your video responses and I will
definitely see you soon alright bye bye
Selah I'm sorry I forgot about you
totally I didn't wake you up did I